mes yeux ne suivent pas de gauche à droite
et ma lèvre supérieure ne bouge pas, ce qui
signifie que je ne peux pas sourire voici pourquoi je m'appelle
la fille qui ne peut pas sourire tu sais que
nous devrions tous pouvoir grandir dans un
monde  où nous sommes tous acceptés, mais pour
moi, je ne l'étais pas et j'ai vraiment lutté avec
ça et cela a vraiment
eu un impact sur ma santé mentale dans une
mesure vraiment extrême
[Musique]
donc je suis né avec un
trouble neurologique très rare appelé
syndrome de Mobius euh  ce syndrome est si rare
qu'il n'affecte qu'une personne et
tous les trois à quatre millions um et ce
syndrome affecte mes sixième et septième
nerfs crâniens et à cause du
syndrome j'ai été victime d'intimidation à un
degré vraiment traumatisant et tout au long
de ma vie scolaire ça a commencé  avec
des injures puis moche et
sans valeur et que mes parents ne
m'aimaient pas et toutes ces choses folles
alors que c'était vraiment difficile pour moi de
traverser et de m'isoler super vous savez
comme si je n'avais jamais vraiment eu un solide groupe d'
amis et
J'ai toujours eu l'impression que je n'étais pas assez bon
parce que je ne pouvais pas sourire, mais tu sais,
traverser tout cela et euh vraiment
me rendre à un endroit où je
me sens assez bien m'a
vraiment aidé, tu sais, j'ai eu ma
première tentative de suicide  à l'âge de 12 ans,
puis a fait six autres
tentatives de suicide jusqu'à
l'âge d'environ 19 ans. les toilettes ont pris
ma santé mentale euh était vraiment mauvaise vous
savez en 2015
16 on m'a diagnostiqué une dépression clinique extrême
anxiété  avec un trouble de stress post-traumatique
et des attaques dissociatives
et donc les attaques dissociatives étaient
essentiellement mon cerveau qui s'arrêtait de
tous les traumatismes qu'il avait subis à travers tous
les problèmes de santé mentale avec lesquels il
luttait je m'effondrais et j'avais des crises
jusqu'à huit ou neuf fois  un jour
pendant une bonne partie de quatre mois vraiment euh
et des médecins et des spécialistes m'ont dit
que je n'allais jamais complètement
récupérer et que je serais aux prises avec
ces
problèmes de santé pour le reste de ma vie
parce que c'était si mauvais euh
toi  sais qu'on me dit cela à l'âge
de vous savez 1920 et c'est à ce moment-là que vous êtes
censé obtenir toute votre
indépendance dans la vie et sortir et
vivre vos rêves et tout ce genre de
choses et on m'a dit que j'étais
va devoir dépendre d'autres personnes
toute ma vie et
je pense qu'il m'a fallu un certain temps pour
comprendre que je détenais en moi le pouvoir
de me remettre sur la bonne voie
j'ai été mis en thérapie intensive parce que
j'étais dans et hors du  système hospitalier
avec ma santé mentale, mais euh ce
n'est vraiment que vers l'âge de 21 ans juste
après mon 21e anniversaire en fait où j'ai
finalement décidé que
ce serait soit à moi de
changer le cours de la vie que je
descendais  ou j'allais continuer à
me sentir impuissant et triste alors je suis vraiment
dans ma forme physique et ma santé et je sortais
marcher tous les jours je suis entré dans la
méditation j'ai écouté tellement de
listes de lecture de musique différentes sur spotify je
regardais des vidéos drôles sur youtube juste
pour essayer  et me sortir de cet
état d'esprit négatif, puis créer vraiment
une
sorte de routine habituelle que je pourrais suivre pour que
vous sachiez que me lever à une certaine heure
et aller me promener et ne pas vérifier mon
téléphone pendant la première heure de la journée m'a
vraiment aidé  moi et je
lis définitivement tous les jours pendant très longtemps,
aidez-moi et méditez et travaillez sur mon
travail respiratoire et assurez-vous vraiment
que j'ai des choses tout au long de ma journée
chaque jour qui
me garderont dans un bon état d'esprit, peu importe
ce que euh et je pense que créer cette habitude
pour moi-même a complètement changé ma vie,
alors en grandissant toute ma vie,
j'ai été un athlète j'ai concouru pour la
nouvelle-zélande en natation et
en shopping en tant qu'athlète paralympique et
le sport a toujours été  une si grande partie
de ma vie et je pense que
sans le sport, je ne sais pas trop
où je serais, ce qui est une chose si effrayante à laquelle
penser, mais je pense que la pensée a été un
exutoire créatif pour moi pendant très
longtemps et pas  seulement cela m'a aidé, je suppose, à
échapper à ce que je traversais dans tous
les autres aspects de ma vie, cela m'a donné
un endroit pour vraiment concentrer mon attention
et
être dédié à quelque chose, cela m'a juste
donné un exutoire pour
respirer et me concentrer uniquement  sur
autre chose plutôt que sur tout ce qui se
passait ici
[Musique]
je pense que tu sais que j'ai tellement appris
en traversant ce que j'ai
traversé et les gens pensent que je suis fou quand
je dis ça mais je suis tellement  reconnaissant pour
tout ce que j'ai traversé parce que
non seulement cela a fait de moi la personne
que je suis aujourd'hui, mais cela m'a également donné
une perspective et une vision vraiment uniques
de la vie, je pense que la principale
chose que je dirais aux gens qui
se sentent peut-être  isolés dans leur propre vie ou non
acceptés par la société ou les gens qui
les entourent ou essaient de respecter une
norme à laquelle ils ne s'adapteront jamais,
je dirais que ces personnes dont vous savez que
nous sommes tous nés pour une raison nous '  vous êtes tous
ici sur cette terre pour une raison et
même si vous ne comprenez pas
cela ou ne connaissez pas cette réponse en ce moment,
sachez simplement que vous êtes si nécessaire dans ce
monde,
vous comptez pour vos
passions, les choses qui vous
passionnent comptent comme vous ne l'êtes pas
stupide de vouloir faire des choses que vous
voulez vraiment faire ou d'être qui vous voulez
être et je pense que si j'ai appris quelque chose,
c'est que peu importe ce que nous pouvons tous
faire, réaliser tout ce que nous voulons dans cette
vie et j'espère vraiment que  mon histoire peut
inspirer les gens à comprendre cela et à
réaliser cela et à poursuivre ce qu'ils
veulent dans cette vie parce que
vous savez, même s'il m'a fallu
traverser beaucoup de choses pour réaliser que
je suis sorti de l'autre côté et que j'ai compris
que nous sommes tous  capables de tant de
choses dans cette vie, nous sommes tous incroyables
et uniques ici pour une raison